here is gay pedar Transportation
secretary who only got hired because
he's gay as you know he was the mayor of
a small town South Bend Indiana has no
qualifications to be in charge of
Transportation literally none whatsoever
but he cut a deal with Biden to get out
of the race and uh he's gay so you know
it's spectacular here he is with uh
Democrat activist Jake Tapper on CNN uh
talking about the balloon
the military gauge the different risks
and the different uh benefits of
different approaches made the decisions
that they did brought this thing down
with that incident right but the
presumption has got to be that the
Chinese were able to gather intelligence
hovering over the United States for day
after day especially over some of these
sensitive sites I'm sure there's a
similar presumption about what Spy
satellites do that is well outside of my
Lane I'm just glad that nobody was hurt
as this thing came down I don't know I
don't even know why
that's out of my way I mean look it's so
ridiculous these people so this thing
was flying over military sites we have
no in no idea what information pictures
video audio we have simply no idea where
they were they looking at critical
infrastructure we have no idea but then
they send bootage Edge out there to talk
about something that he admits he has no
idea what he's supposed to be talking
about
[Music]
foreign